you touch on a lot of things that i'm
going to be talking about today so
so thanks um so you know as michael said
i'm selima murshi i'm a researcher at
microsoft research
in the chill group which stands for
computer human interactive learning
uh and i'm gonna talk to you today about
some of the work that our group is doing
along with in collaboration with also a
number of other folks at msr
and you know some fabulous interns that
we've had on how we can work towards
more usable
machine learning um and you know feel
free to throughout the talk if you have
questions you know just
just raise your hand and let me know um
so first of all you know why
why do we care about machine learning so
you know we care about machine learning
because
we have all of this data right we have
all this data that's being collected
about
about us from our interactions you know
on the web
or interactions with our computers and
from all our sensory equipped
devices and you know machine learning is
this really powerful way of sort of
transforming the raw data that we have
out there
into usable information and so what i
mean by usable information i mean sort
of a machine learned
model that can be used to to make
predictions um
and these these models are what we can
deploy in our applications in order to
automate our tasks right so we can use
them to sort of automatically detect
objects or patterns and data
we can use them to sort of automatically
try to organize and manage our
information
as well as sort of predict future
behaviors
and so the way that this works at least
with supervised machine learning
is uh something like this where you know
given some
some label data where the x's here are
the data and the y's are the labels on
the data
the goal is to learn some function that
can predict the labels on new data
so that's that's the overall idea of
supervised machine learning uh but now
in practice what really happens is
there's this guy right there's a guy
who's responsible for collecting some
data
creating some features uh and oh this is
the guy
he's responsible you know getting
getting the data together creating
features tweaking algorithm parameters
and then sending all this information to
a machine learning algorithm
in order to try to learn this function
and this is you know typically an
iterative process in that this guy's not
going to get it right the first time
right he often has to look at
how well the machine is performing and
you know try to inspect
what's happening and then try to improve
the model by continually trying to
supply it with more and more information
until it's working the way he wants it
to
then the output of this process is is a
model that's really encapsulating this
learned function
and this model like i said you know can
be deployed then in in your applications
and then your applications can now you
know take a new data and and can be can
use this model to make predictions
so you know for example uh machine
learned models are being used you know
in everything from sort of recommending
interesting content to you on the web so
music recommendations or you know
facebook or twitter posts
um to predicting you know the relevance
of ads for you
even to you know like detecting fraud or
you know detecting even the outbreak of
diseases
the problem is that you know while
machine learning is being used for a lot
of these really important tasks
the models that people create are not
always accurate and that's because you
know models are
really a function of both a complicated
algorithm and complex data
which means that you know sometimes they
can predict pick up on sort of
patterns that aren't really there and
those can lead to sort of bad
predictions
and so the consequences of you know
these sort of inaccurate models can
range from
you know being benign where you know you
might get some you know unwanted twitter
or facebook posts
or irrelevant content recommendations to
really you know damaging where
financial or political decisions are
being made based on inaccurate
predictions
or worse yet are made based on you know
predictions that might encode some
inherent biases in the models
and so you know machine learning people
are working on this right they're
working on trying to improve machine
learning algorithms
um so that they can make better
predictions or make them more
efficiently
um and we need that uh but you know we
have to remember that there's you know
also this guy
right this guy is you know the one who's
like providing the algorithm with
information
and it is iteratively trying to debug
the performance of the models that
um that are being built and so you know
the ability of this guy to effectively
train
these algorithms really directly impacts
um the performance of the models that
are being built
and the problem is not that this guy
doesn't have the right skills
although that can also be a problem but
even machine learning experts you know
have difficulty
building models or understanding exactly
how their models that they build are
going to perform
in the wild and on on totally new data
and you know in fact you know these
human limitations are something that
machine learning researchers are aware
of you know they try to design
algorithms to account for some of these
human limit limitations
themselves right so for example there's
a lot of work being done on designing
algorithms that can work in the face of
like
noisy data or insufficient data that
might come from a human
but you know there's also sort of
another strategy there's a complimentary
strategy which is you know
instead of trying to deal with human
limitations in the algorithms
we can actually try to improve human
abilities by you know
trying to design new tools and
interfaces in order to try to you know
reduce or prevent
noisy human input altogether and you
know this is what i'm going to talk
about today
um i'm going to give you a couple of
examples of some of the work that our
group is doing uh in the space
where we're trying to sort of shift some
of our attention over to the user
and try to design new ways for this guy
or people
to better interact with machine learning
systems
um so i'm going to give you a couple of
examples of this
like i said so i'm going to talk first
of all on about something to do with the
input side which
is what we call structured labeling so
it has to do with how people provide
labeled data
to machine learning systems um and then
i'll talk uh
in the second half of the talk about the
output side and so how we consider
design uh better tools for people to
understand the performance of their
models and then at the end i'll talk
about some of the other work that our
group
is doing in the space and some of the
open opportunities there
okay so structured labeling so this was
a project
we did a couple years ago with a an
intern of mine from oregon state todd
kalisa
as well as several other folks at msr
and just to give you
a little bit of content context recall
that supervised machine learning
systems learn from labeled data now
oftentimes people are actually recruited
to manually label large data sets for
the purpose of training these algorithms
which you know seems simple enough but
the problem is that
labeling data is actually not really as
easy as it seems and this is something
that michael talked about
right um when people label data they're
they're labeling
according to some target concept that's
in their heads
right so for example uh imagine i was
asked to label web pages
as being about cooking or not related to
cooking
so what i would do is i would start
labeling some examples that are you know
clearly about cooking
so um this is a recipe page so it
clearly has something to do with cooking
here's another example then i would
label some pages that are clearly
not about cooking so these are have
nothing to do
with sort of cooking then i might come
across a page that looks like this
right so this is a page as a catering
page which is you know kind of like
cooking
you know um you know it kind of it's
about sort of preparing food so
i might say at this point that yes you
know this is about cooking
then you know i'd keep going um labeling
more and more examples more positive
examples and more negative examples
and then i might come across a page that
looks like this right so this page is
you know kind of like that catering page
and that's you know it's about um
someone coming to your house and
preparing food for you
but you know at this point if i think
about it maybe i would say that you know
this is really not
about cooking it's about someone else
cooking for you it's not really about
the process of cooking
so maybe at this point i'll say that you
know this is actually not about cooking
okay so that's the problem right the
problem is that i just inconsistently
labeled my data
right i labeled this page as not about
cooking but that previous page
as about cooking and you know did i even
remember that i did that like
and are there more pages like that you
can imagine if you have hundreds or
thousands of data points you know
will you remember that how you labeled
previous examples
do you need to go back and find them and
move them now that you've changed your
mind about
what you want to consider as part of
your concept
so the problem is that the concept that
people
are labeling for is evolving as they
observe data
and so to understand sort of how much of
a problem this actually was
uh we did a study where we had nine
machine learning experts
label the same set of data over two
sessions about four weeks apart
and what we found was that even machine
learning experts
were only about eighty percent
consistent with themselves on labeling
the exact same set of data
and in fact six out of the nine people's
um labels change significantly from one
session to the next
okay so so this concept evolution you
know it happens it's something that
happens to the user
something's happening in their heads as
they label data but the tools that we
have
don't allow us to sort of easily revise
and refine our concepts as we go along
and this can sort of be both frustrating
to the user if they want to change their
minds
but also can be harmful to some machine
learning algorithms that you know
fundamentally assume similar items have
have similar labels yes
yeah is that is that evidence of
evolution
which would be sort of like a changing
bias or is that just evidence of sort of
randomness in my labeling
yeah there's some randomness that
happens um but there's also
changes and and we sort of see this in
the in the study that i'll talk about
because we see that people
do want to change their mind and they do
move things around
um and even when you when you work with
machine learning folks or people who are
labeling data
they often like will will use our system
and then come to us and say like
well i changed my mind and i and i want
to make all of those examples that i
labeled
for this subconcept in a different way
and really the only way they can do that
is to go through every example
find those or search for them somehow
and move it
so so it's a bit of both um and i'll
talk a little bit more about this at the
end because like some some algorithms
can
can actually can handle some noise um
and it's actually can be good for some
machine learning algorithms
whereas some algorithms are more
affected by noise so
so you know there there there's there's
differences there but people
having people sort of understand how the
label can can lower their frustration
can lower a lot of their anxiety which
we also sort of found in the study
um and so i'll actually show you with
the tool we came up with to sort of help
people with this process um
uh it's actually a technique that we
call structured labeling
uh where we essentially allowed people
to sort of explicitly organize uh their
concept
um using sort of grouping and tagging
within a traditional labeling scheme
so uh what i mean by that is that
instead of something like this where you
sort of force people to categorize data
at a high level
we had something like this where we
allowed people to create subgroups
within these high-level categories
so for example um if i had you know came
across this catering page and if i was
unsure about it
what i could do is create a subgroup for
it within the cooking category
and then i can tag that subgroup maybe
with something like
catering so that i could sort of
remember how i labeled examples of this
kind
which means that you know what that does
is that it's surfacing my labeling
decisions to myself so that later on
you know when i come across like other
catering examples
i can say that well you know this is
actually very related to that other
catering page that i saw so i can group
them together
and then later on if i decide that maybe
catering should not be part of my
concept
i can easily revise uh my my concept by
moving the whole group at once um
so so these groups and tags sort of you
know not only allow me to
recall and revise my labeling decisions
as we go along
it actually lets people sort of defer my
decision make their decision making
um so that's what i was sort of
referring to so people often sort of
agonize about like how they should label
data
you know if i came across that catering
page you know i might you know should
this be positive should this be negative
i don't know
and oftentimes people get you know very
afraid of like how
what their labels are going to do and so
what this does is it sort of allows
people to
defer their decision making right so
they can tag things that they might not
be sure about and they can always go
back and revise
them later if they change their mind as
they observe more and more data
so we also came up with an assisted
version of the structured labeling tool
um to sort of deal with a few problems
that we saw
during a pilot study with with the tool
so
first of all what we noticed was that
sometimes oftentimes actually people
didn't provide
tags for the groups that they created um
so so you know they would sort of
create these subgroups quickly you know
put things aside that they weren't sure
about but they didn't want to put an
effort to sort of write tags for them
but then later on when they you know
recall that they created a group
of something you know before they'd have
to actually like look into the groups
um in order to see what they had put
into all of them and you know that was a
big pain
so um to help people that um we provided
automatic summaries um for
for the people of the groups that they
created so this is just using the
the text in the groups uh that people
created um just to
help them sort of recall what each group
was in case they didn't manually tag it
but we still allowed them to do that as
well
we also found that when people were
labeling they would often remember
creating groups with similar items to
the one that they were currently trying
to label
but they would forget sort of exactly
where which group they had put those
similar items in
and so what we did was um we provided
recommendations
uh based on the similarity between the
current item a person was trying to
label and
the the groups that they already created
um so this was this little star here
um and so that was sort of the system
sort of suggesting well you put
something similar
like this in this group so that might
help them sort of decide
where how to group things uh
another interesting thing that we saw
was that you know people didn't want to
sort of put in the effort to
make these labeling decisions for items
that they thought were sort of outliers
so you know if there's only sort of one
catering example in all of my data then
it doesn't really matter whether i
consider it positive or negative
but it's if that example is sort of
representative of a lot of a larger
con sub concept that i really want my
model to recognize
then i might want to put in more effort
to label it
and so uh to deal with this what we did
was um we
we showed people similar examples um to
the example that they were currently
trying to label so we would show sort of
the things that the system thought
thought were similar just to give them a
sense of like how sort of big this group
is and whether or not
they should sort of bother trying to to
structure their labels for
okay so you know we did an evaluation to
understand uh to try to understand so
the impacts that structured labeling had
on the labeling task where we
had you know fishing participants come
in we had within subjects design so we
had them use each of these
different conditions the traditional
labeling tool as well as the manual and
assisted structured labeling tools
we had them label 100 pages and we had
them label for a few different concepts
that we thought people were sort of
be relatively familiar with
and what we found was that you know
participants did indeed use structured
labeling when it was available
um we found that people created
significantly more groups
in both the structured labeling
conditions than compared to the
traditional labeling where they couldn't
do that
but interestingly we we noticed that
people
tended to create fewer but larger groups
with the assisted condition
and that's probably because the system
was making recommendations about where
where the subgroups were or where how
they should create these subgroups
based on their previous um labeling
decisions
uh we also found that you know people
revised and revisited uh their labels
significantly more with the structured
labeling tools than with the traditional
tools so this
sort of gets back to the ideas like is
it noise or are people sort of really
trying to change their minds or or
wanting to sort of understand their
labeling decisions so people
were looking back and they were trying
to change things as
when they were when they had a tool that
allowed them to do so
um so we also looked at like the
consistency of people's labels
uh and found that uh with both
structured labeling tools
uh people uh labeled significantly more
consistently
than with the traditional labeling tool
with no real significance
difference between the manual and the
assisted conditions
so you know this is this is great this
is what we wanted um
but uh the the consistency and the
ability to evolve your concept
did come at a cost right it actually
took people longer
to complete the labeling task with the
structured labeling conditions
which you know makes sense because
people are putting you know they have to
do more work they have to create these
subgroups and decide decide
how to tag them and which groups to
create but
interestingly when we looked at sort of
the difference in how long it took
people to label
uh in the first half of the study versus
the second half
we saw that this difference in speed uh
really decreased
and this was likely due to people sort
of converging after a while on on what
they wanted the definition of their
concept to be
so there's some upfront cost to having
the structure but it decreases over time
we also found that you know people
preferred the structured labeling
condition for most tasks saying that you
know it helped them to sort of
organize the items that they they wanted
to label
um interestingly uh in terms of the
assisted condition
some people said that they preferred it
because it actually sort of converted
a decision-making task into sort of a
verification one
right so with the with the
recommendations the user can say like
well you know actually i want it to be
somewhere else instead of having to
decide
how they want to label um and you know
of course you know there
some people did say that they they
prefer the traditional tool because you
know it's simple
um but those p a lot of those people you
know wanted the structured labeling tool
in certain cases where they were sort of
less familiar with their concept right
so if you know exactly what you want to
be what you want to include as positive
or negative examples then
maybe you don't need a structured
labeling tool but if you know you're
sort of more fuzzy on the concept then
then having something like this they
thought would be helpful
okay so um to summarize you know people
you know people evolve their concepts
as they observe data but the current
tools that people have you know don't
allow them
to sort of revise and recall their
decision making
and so we proposed this this technique
called structure labeling to help them
and found that you know people did use
it and it helped improve uh
help them label more consistently and so
sort of going back to the consistency
issue like i said
um some algorithms are more affected by
labeling inconsistency than others
uh particularly like highly expressive
algorithms um
can try to overfit to the to the noise
and the data and so they may be more
effective than less expressive ones
um but even regardless this is something
that's you know happening to the user
right so
the it's causing frustration to the user
if they want to change their mind about
how they want their algorithms to behave
so something that's still happening
that can still benefit the labelers
themselves
and the structure also itself
contains information right it contains
information that you can use in order to
so you know come up with
features for example that can sort of
help your algorithm learn about sort of
these sub-concepts
it contains information you know we can
we can sort of measure the performance
of your model on each of the different
subclusters which can help you sort of
make
decisions about what you want to include
or or not so there's a lot of actual
information that's contained within
these these groups and tags that we can
also use
in order to try to improve the
performance of the models that we build
um okay so i mean other questions about
structured labeling so this is just sort
of one way that we're trying to help
help people better interact with machine
learning systems
um i'm gonna talk about uh sort of the
output side after that if they're
there are no questions right now we
could also have questions at the end
okay um i'll keep going uh so
so uh model tracker um has to do
with the output side of this process um
which is sort of you know this when
people are for building models they need
to sort of understand the performance of
the models in order to try
to iterate and so you know
what happens in this process is that
when you're building a model
the output that you see in every
iteration
should directly influence your
subsequent actions right that's that's
really the idea of seeing sort of
performance results
if your model is performing poorly then
you're going to try to go in and fix it
the problem is that most of the time
what we see at the stage
is something like this right some number
that summarizes the overall performance
of your model
the problem is that you know what does
that really tell you right it can signal
that there is a problem
but it doesn't really tell you anything
about you know where those problems are
or how you should deal with them or what
you should deal with first
and even if you're lucky and if you have
several summary statistics
or you know the the sort of standard uh
confusion matrices or prediction
precision recall curves sort of the
standard techniques that people use to
understand the performance of their
models
all of these techniques convey the
existence of errors but they don't tell
you where those
those errors are or what you should do
about that
them and you know for that uh what you
usually have to do
is actually switch to you know a
different tool or a different mode
to actually like pull up your data or
visualize your errors
um and these types of tools are often
you know heavy heavyweight meaning that
you often have to sort of convert your
data into different form and then use a
different tool to visualize
and even if you have like a a tool that
that can do that
once you've loaded up your data you
still have to sort of sort and filter in
order to find errors and then try to
gain insights about what the problems
might be
so the problem is that this you know
switching between these summary
statistics to
heavyweight tools for debugging can
actually be very disruptive to
your primary task which is to build a
model
and in fact you know this problem has
been shown um
to lead to a trial and error approach to
model building
meaning that um people instead of like
looking at their data
at every iteration to try to see what's
happening they will randomly try to
change parameters of their model tweak
parameters or add features
in order to try to make these summary
statistics go up
right and then only when that fails then
will they actually sort of resort to
looking at their data
and trying to sort of understand what's
really going on
so the model tracker project was really
you know us trying to figure out how we
could sort of encourage people or enable
people to take a more informed approach
to model building
um so i will
attempt to demo demo the tool
so let me switch
this
okay cool um okay so
let me go back so it's a little bit slow
okay
so so this is um this whole system is
called ice
interactive classification and
extraction um and this is
a platform that our group at msr is
building um
to enable non-experts to build
classifiers and entity extractors
over big data um in you know one sitting
in a few hours
um and so you know i won't be able to
talk a lot about it today but you know
for the purposes of this talk just you
just need to know this is
that up here is where you would like
label data so i could say these are
positive or negative
um and submit data to my model and over
on the left is where a person can sort
of provide
features for for their models to learn
with
now um in this case i've already built a
model using ice so
i've i've tried to train a classifier to
recognize whether web pages are
about cycling or not cycling so in this
case i've already labeled about 511
items and provided six features
now in ice what we used to have are
is what you see here below these are the
sort of summaries standard summary
statistics and graphs that you might use
when you're
using trying to use machine learning so
people sort of would interact with their
system
label data create features and then look
at these summary statistics in order to
try to see what's going
on and then when they thought there was
a problem
they would switch over to a review mode
where they could do things like
sort and filter so they could filter by
errors
and it's a little bit slow but they'll
pull up sort of the data
that's that you've already labeled
that's in error and then you can sort of
page through those
those items in order to try to sort of
gain some
insights and understand what's going on
this should be pulling up data but it's
a little slow but you get the idea
um so uh what we did in this project was
um replace all of these standard summary
statistics and graphs
with this single visualization which you
see here below which we call model
tracker
so i'll explain what it's showing
so each of these little boxes
corresponds to an example that i've
already labeled
so in this case i've labeled 511
examples so there's 511 boxes
the color of the box is the label that i
gave so if i said something was positive
it's going to be
green if i said something is negative
it's going to be red
now the boxes are laid out horizontally
according to
my classifier score with low scoring
examples to the left and
high scoring examples to the right so
what that means is what i want this
visualization to look like
is i want all my green boxes to be on
the right and all my red boxes to be on
the left
right because that would mean that my
system is very much agreeing with with
what i told it to
um and it similarly errors are also
visible in this way because errors are
the red boxes that are
to the right so red boxes that are that
are getting uh high scores
and green boxes that are shown to the
left
so what this is doing is it's showing me
performance right it's showing me where
my errors are
but unlike with summary statistics that
sort of treat all errors equally
this is actually showing me not only my
errors but it's
showing me sort of the severity of my
errors where more severe sort of errors
more egregious errors are sort of the
ones that are at the far ends of these
visual the visualization because that's
where
the system and i very much disagree as
opposed to sort of this uncertain middle
area where where the system is sort of
more confused
so what that does is it allows people to
sort of prioritize their efforts in
debugging
um and you know in addition you know
because we're showing data at the item
level
you can actually click on these right
you can actually like click on them to
to pull up the errors directly so it's
providing you direct
access to your data so you don't have to
go search for
for problems um and then try to sort of
gain some insights from them and figure
out what's going on so for
in this case you know i clicked on this
this green box which is at the far left
corner so the
something i labeled as positive but the
system's giving a really low score
um and this page you know so i was
trying to create a classifier that can
recognize whether a page is about
cycling
or not this is actually a recycling page
so
that i actually label this positive so
that's that's actually a mislabel on my
part
and that actually happens quite often so
what i can do
is directly change it so i can change my
label
update my model and then the system will
uh retrain possibly
and uh it would update this
visualization once it like retrained
um so again you'll have to imagine but
like it would fix the error and then
the the visualization would try would
update um
and to yeah some something's not like
or something's failing but that's the
idea the idea is you can directly access
the errors and and sort of look at them
um and then try to sort of fix them as
you go along yes
examples yeah so um if you notice like
so when i click on these boxes you see
these lines that are
showing up connecting the item that i
clicked on to other examples
um it's actually showing me and it will
pull up the other examples that i'm
connected to so it's showing me examples
that the system
thinks is very similar in my current
feature space
and the idea behind that was that if
there are
examples that you label differently but
the system sees as very much the same in
the feature space
that likely means that there's a feature
problem it's
you're seeing something that the system
is not seeing because it thinks these
two are very different
so in that case you know that can give
you information about how to debug and
then you might you can add a feature
in order to try to fix your error and i
would show that now but i'm afraid it
won't like update so
maybe i can show a little video at the
end um just to give you a sense of
what the update looks like um
so so so that's what model tracker shows
um
but so i want to explain that also model
tracker actually
subsumes the same information that we
see in all of these summary statistics
and graphs
so so i want to explain that so first of
all confusion matrices
um so are people familiar with confusion
matrices okay
so so confusion matrices um you know
we're just showing you the agreements
and disagreements between um
your labels and the system's predictions
right so things that i labeled as
positive
in this case there's 34 examples that i
labeled as positive that the system also
thinks is possible
positive but there are seven examples
that are in error seven examples that i
said was positive and the
system said was negative so showing you
agreements and disagreements
model tracker you also see agreements
and disagreements you're seeing you know
errors um
disagreements are red boxes to the right
and green boxes to the left
and agreements are our green boxes to
the right and red boxes to the left
but now unlike with confusion matrices
which are threshold dependent model
tracker is actually threshold
independent so what do i mean so
so for to create a confusion matrix you
have to set a threshold right so
if i wanted to sort of see the
performance of my model at a different
threshold i would actually have to
change the threshold so that we have a
slider here that allows us to do that
and then you would be able to generate a
new confusion matrix matrix to see
sort of what the performance is at that
threshold
um with model tracker you can see the
performance um at all thresholds
at once so you can see that you know so
we have a threshold line here
but actually it doesn't serve any
functional purpose it just serves as a
visual aid
and so what it can do is like if i you
know if i move my
my threshold to the right i can see that
you know i'm reducing the number of
false positives because i have fewer red
boxes to the right
but it's coming at a cost of false
negatives because now i have more
green boxes that are to the to the left
so you can sort of see the trade-off
between
your false positives and false negatives
that your agreements and disagreements
at all thresholds at once so if you
wanted to see the sort of same
information with confusion matrices you
know you would need
one of these for each threshold that
you're interested in which you know can
be up to like a hundred
um model tracker also shows you the same
information that you would see in
precision recall curves
um are people familiar with precision
recalculation you know
is um it's the number of
true positives over the number of true
positives and
false positives and recall is sort of
the number the true positives over
um true positives and false negatives
something like that and you know if
that's
confusing you know don't worry because
it's confusing for everybody like it's
even even machine learning experts i i
often see sort of trying to do this
mental mapping in their head like
so precision is is this over this and
what does that actually translate to
um with model tracker you can actually
see this um directly so
um precision and model tracker are the
number of green boxes that are to the
right
of this threshold line right so in this
case you know i'm doing i'm doing pretty
well
in terms of precision because most of
what you see on the right
is is positive but recall so recall is
the number of green boxes that are to
the right and so there's a lot of green
boxes that
the system is predicting as negative so
i'm actually doing pretty bad in terms
of recall
and so you can actually see the the
precision recall trade off at the
various thresholds as well because
you know if i were to move my threshold
line to the left
i'd be increasing recall because you
know more green boxes are being
predicted as positive
but it's clearly coming at a cost of
precision because now also
more false i'm predicting more red boxes
as positive um so you can see see all of
that
as well so you can see sort of what what
the standard precision recall curves
will show you
um so subsuming all of the information
that we would normally see but also
providing you direct access to your
errors so that we can sort of encourage
people to look at their data
and understand what's going on with
every iteration
we also do a whole bunch of other things
like because you're showing data at the
item level
you can do you can do a lot of
annotations to this so you might notice
some of these annotations i have here so
i've sort of tagged items that i want to
sort of
keep track of and so you know as i'm
going along if i try to fix
those errors i might want to tag it to
see if it actually got fixed as a result
of my action
so i can do that you see these little
circles here
those are showing me sort of outliers
this isn't what the system thinks are
outliers so that can sort of give me
additional debugging information
if i look at one of those i might be
able to i might see that maybe
um it's showing me something that it's
only seen one example of this kind so i
might need to provide more examples
you know we can also show feature
information so if i hover over these
features i can sort of see
how that feature is correlated with my
class so that can sort of help me sort
of debug at the feature level
so there's a lot of things we can do
because we're showing data at the item
level
okay so so that's model tracker um
let me maybe i'll try to
show you a quick video just i'll forward
to like the end of this
i just want you to see sort of how it
would normally look like so so i clicked
on an example
i'm changing the label adding a feature
in order to fix a problem that i've seen
and the system is going to actually like
take that information now and update
um and it can show you you can sort of
track the your progress as you go along
and
and you when you use model tracker if
it's if your model is performing
if it's learning as you go you'll sort
of see these these classes sort of
separate you'd see like green boxes
moving to the right and red box to the
left and if you saw those directed arcs
that's showing you sort of the
the impact of your actions so oftentimes
you know you'll see that with a with
labeling you don't see a lot of
those arcs you don't see big changes but
with featuring you see a lot more and so
that can sort of help you decide whether
or not the effect you thought
was going to happen actually did happen
yes
the extraction sorry would you have time
to show the entity
um i possibly i don't know if it will
come up um um yeah so yeah we do use
model tracker for entity extraction let
me see if i
can let me change my stuff
okay let me go back
oh no it's fine um so
i don't know if i have an entity
extractor available
okay um maybe i'll try to see if it
loads after
after a while um but yeah so so we do
use it for entity extraction
energy extraction can be sort of seen as
sort of a hierarchical multi-class
kind of problem so we actually use it
for that so it can be used so somali
tracker can be used for from multi-class
in that way where we sort of convert a
multi-class problem to a binary
binary problem where error for every
class is either that class or
all of or the rest and so you have to
sort of switch between
different model trackers there's not
necessarily the the best way to do it
and we're sort of looking at
where how we can sort of provide a
single visualization for
for a multi-class but we do use it that
way currently and
and people people will use it and they
seem to like it
um okay so i can skip all these backup
slides since the demo
sort of worked um
okay so you know model tracker deals
with this problem that you know current
tools for performance analysis and
debugging um
you know are either too coarse to
provide insights or disruptive to the
primary task because you have to switch
between them
and so we did a couple evaluations and
tried trying to understand how people
actually would use model tracker
specifically we
wanted to see how people naturally use
model tracker when they were building
models
and how often you know they interacted
with it um and then we also ran a sort
of controlled experiment trying to
understand that
when people are interacting with the
model tracker
are they able to to debug their model's
performance
in the same way as they would if they
were just sort of sorting and filtering
through their data
so first in terms of how people actually
use model tracker
we actually did a six month deployment
where we had seven
uh real users um so by real users i mean
people who are like not part of our team
um and we had them i mean we're real
people too but um you know people who
are not a part of our team and we had
them build
real models meaning models that they
were actually building for research and
product
deployments and what we found was that
people
did in fact use model tracker they use
it in 35 of the 40 sessions
and when they did use it they used it
throughout
the model building process so what this
graph is showing you is how often people
interact with model tracker um over time
and you know you can see that um people
used it um throughout they were
they were clicking on items boxes
throughout the process with a slight
increase
in interaction towards the end yes when
they're
not using model tracker what are they
doing um so in ice
so ice you start from scratch um when
you're building a model so you have to
both
find new examples in a universe in a
large data set of you know we have 50
million web pages
so they're searching and exploring the
universe to find new data
to give as well as creating features
so model tracker is used for debugging
each iteration of that model so if you
find a new pocket of example or new
item island then you know you would
incorporate that into your model and
then you might look at model tractor to
sort of see
whether it got that or not so so yeah
um they're they're doing building the
whole doing the whole iterative model
building process
is your ideal that this number should go
up or down
over time i think um
i would say i would want people to to
have a sort of steady
interaction with it over time right we
wouldn't want them to just
collect all of their data and build all
these features and then debug at the
at the very end because you know what as
as you're going along you might see some
problems which might change the way
change things earlier on it might lead
you in a different direction and change
you might change you know the features
that you have
which you might not have seen if you
weren't looking at your data as you go
along
um so a steady sort of interaction is
what what we really wanted
i was asking a little bit about which
case like if you wanted a higher number
then that would mean people are spending
more time working with your system
developing their models and so on yeah
and that seems good but on the other
hand you also might want a lower number
because that means that
they're being more effective about it
and needing to spend less time finding
their models
interesting i'm just trying to figure
out like
yeah um yeah that's you know
a good question um i think
all machine learning requires iteration
um
and yeah i think they people can be more
effective if they look at their data
earlier um so yeah if
if we're providing like the the best
means for them to like
improve at every iteration then maybe
they only need to interact with it
periodically um but
uh it's yeah it's really hard to say
because like
current tools like that people use they
don't interact with their data very
often and we know it's a problem right
we know that people are sort of taking
this trial and error approach so
so it's hard to say if that's that
they're not looking at their data
because
they're doing better actually it's more
that it's just they're not unable to do
so
so so it might be something that we'd be
able to sort of see over time with more
usage
you know to see what what the effects
are
um no take the average of this and try
to correlate it with like the
yeah like the final model performance
yeah yeah yeah
um definitely yeah um
so another thing we looked at is you
know we wanted to sort of see what
people were actually clicking on in
their data and what we saw was that
people
people did tend to click so this is
showing you sort of the the prediction
scores so
the things at the far ends are sort of
correspond to the far ends of the
visualization so people are sort of
interacting more with
with the data at the far ends um but
they're still sort of clicking on things
on
uh in the middle and we actually talked
to people and they said that that was
actually a strategy that they that they
naturally sort of um
took because you know they felt like the
the problems at the very far ends
had sort of more obvious solutions they
felt you know there are things like
mislabeled data and so there were sort
of the easier things that they wanted to
sort of get rid of first as opposed to
sort of the
the items in the the middle area which
they thought were sort of harder to deal
with so they sort of took the strategy
interestingly you know we also found
that
people of the items that people clicked
on only
40 of them were actually in error at the
time
that um they were clicked and that was
surprising to us we thought that they
would just sort of look at their errors
um but in fact people sort of wanted to
look at other other things as well right
so first of all they wanted to sometimes
check what the system was getting
correct
just to get a sense of like where it's
working well um
but also you know this goes back to sort
of what i said earlier which is that you
know in
typical you know summary statistics and
graphs
um errors are sort of threshold
dependent right
so um with model tracker they're not and
you can click on anything and so
you might click on an example that you
know is technically correct
but it's just you know below the
threshold just above the threshold so
it's still sort of problematic so
people are also wanting to click on on
that and sort of inspect those errors
inspect those examples even though there
might they might technically
uh not be in error
okay so um we also did a control
experiment um comparing model trackers
um
support for debugging um to sort of the
traditional method of looking at your
data
via sort of sorting and filtering
through through lists
so we had 14 people come in we have you
know them
fix a broken model using both model
tracker and the traditional sorting and
filtering
uh and what we found was that our
participants preferred model tracker
over those traditional tools without a
loss in their ability to debug and
actually
find errors and understand what was
going on and that's you know sort of
what we want we want people to look at
their data more
frequently and when they look at it we
still want them to be able to
figure out what's going on and
understand problems
um and so you know people sort of
commented on their experiences and
said things that you know they thought
um the the interface with model trigger
interface was you know more intuitive
and they thought it made you know sort
of the summary statistics and graphs
more accessible
um they like the fact that you know it
was a single visualization it's one
thing they had to sort of keep track of
as opposed to sort of trying to
interpret multiple um summary statistics
and graphs
um and they they also commented on this
the problem that they felt with the
traditional tool which is
switching between these two different
views in order to figure out what's
happening
um and of course you know a couple
people did say that you know they they
were used to
this traditional summary statistics and
graphs and they felt like that you know
if they were
already knew what they meant that maybe
it would be okay but they
a lot of them also said that they wanted
some combination of the two and
still having abil the ability to see the
overall summary statistics
but having model tracker to access their
data
okay so to summarize uh you know we
built model tracker to
help people during this performance
analysis stage um during model building
and i showed you how you know model
tracker actually sort of subsumes
information contained in
numerous summary statistics and graphs
uh while providing direct access to your
data
and we found that you know people
naturally use model tracker throughout
the model building
and preferred it over these traditional
tools without a loss in their debugging
ability
okay so um so you know i talked about
like how
you know just like we have people
working on trying to improve machine
learning algorithms
um we also have like a really important
opportunity i believe you know to
improve
the tools and techniques that um people
use the people who are involved in the
machine learning process
we have the the opportunity to improve
those systems and i gave two examples of
this today i'm looking at sort of both
the
input side and the output side of this
problem but you know there's a lot of
opportunities remaining in the space
you know on the input side there's you
know helping people come up with
features i think you know still
it's hard for people to think of new
features so um there's opportunities
there it's hard for people to explore
large data sets and and find data to
include in their models
it's hard for people to figure out which
parameters how to set the parameters
for for the various algorithms they
might try to use
and you know on the output side you know
there's a lot of opportunities there as
well right like i showed you model
tracker which is really designed for
binary even though we use it for
multi-class
problems but i think there's there's
more we can do there there's
opportunities also to work with
different types of algorithms that
uh if you can sort of visualize the flow
of data through different algorithms i
think
would be sort of really interesting and
really helpful for people
interacting with machine learning and i
think you know this is where hci
can really help um i think it's you know
we're we're trained to sort of
understand
tasks and understand whether the tools
that people use are actually helping
them
accomplish those tasks um so i think hdi
can help with you know identifying where
these problems are because
that's hard for for for people not in
hdi because they're so used to using
these tools that they've been using for
for a long time so having a fresh
perspective to understand whether the
tools they're using
are actually effective and then hdi can
also sort of help with
coming up with new solutions to those to
those problems right so designing new
ways for people to interact
i think there's sort of a lot of
opportunities for hci to help uh with
machine learning
and you know i i really only sort of
focus on the interface side of this
problem the how the user can better
better interact with these systems but i
think you know advances uh in interfaces
really go hand in hand with
advances in algorithms because you know
the insights that we gain with
understanding users can impact the
algorithms we create
and vice versa so i think there are a
lot of opportunities for collaboration
across hdi and machine learning and
visualization as well
okay so um this is what our group does
at msr the chill group
computer human interactive learning um
we're building all these things that
i talked about and others into our ice
system
that i mentioned earlier uh which we're
moving to the web
soon um so soon hopefully you know
you'll be able to use it if you want to
like
if you're doing uh work where you need
to sort of build a model and want to
deploy it and see how you know
enable some application you can do that
as well so if you're interested you know
contact me
we're also you know if you we're always
looking for great
interns you know if you're interested in
the space though feel free to talk to me
about that after as well
so thanks i can take questions now
a little bit yeah it's um i feel like
the
through hard one experience you start to
learn that
small differences in classifier
confidence
are not necessarily interpretable nor
should you like pay tons of attention to
them like clearly there's like
strong positive strong negative
but i wanted to sort of pick your brain
a little bit about why you chose
this continuous layout that sort of
accentuates the fact that like
this is very close to this but slight
slightly more confident than this one
yeah
where those those differences may or may
not actually be something that would be
productive to focus on
right and maybe within noise so to speak
yeah and i think
i don't think we i don't think people
sort of
look at it in that way they don't i
think globally they look
they see they compare they see that
there's these
problems at the far end but between
things that are sort of
near each other we don't see sort of a
lot of people saying well this one's
like slightly better than this
um uh at least we didn't see that like
during the studies that we had
so i think so people get a sense that
like these are you know relatively close
to each other so
that's okay the problems are like the
the bigger differences and and how to
how to fix those she's pulled them over
or is the week before good week
yeah so it seems to me
like the target user for this at the
moment are people who are
already machine learning experts already
doing this sort of work
do you see any sort of opportunities to
bring in people
like novices or people who are not
machine learning experts and like
applications
for that yeah um for valve tracker or in
general
um yeah yeah well so
um with the model tracker the settings
we did we had um
actual a range of users so not all all
of them were machine learning experts
um ice is actually designed for
non-experts so we have some people who
are
somewhat familiar with machine learning
but but not um wouldn't consider
themselves as experts
um and i think you know that is
something we really
want um and something like model tracker
i think is actually useful for for
novices because you can
you can learn by seeing the effects of
your actions over time right you can see
that features make bigger differences
than labels and that's something that
maybe machine learning experts are
already familiar with but the novices
maybe are not
um but it also just happens that like
machine learning experts
want this like to use this tool too
right because it was just hard for them
to
to access their data beforehand so so i
think
it benefits both and i think yeah i
think there's a whole spectrum of
dealing with
end users even so people who are not
even trying to build models but just
trying to use
machine learning machine learning models
in their day-to-day lives
when they're making content
recommendations you know right now
there's not a lot of tools for people to
steer those recommendation recommenders
to sort of
suggest things that they're interested
in except for liking and disliking
things
to experts who are you know trying to
build new algorithms in this so
there's a spectrum and i think some of
these tools can translate
and work well across the board and some
you need to design
um specifically to the application and
task at hand
yeah yeah the first one is i think this
is great the model tracker is great
um i'm a little confused about um
so it's really great when you think
about changing mislabeled data right
uh but every time you change your data
you would probably have
tuned your hyper parameters again so
this is my application take that into
account at all when it retrains every
time you change your data because
presumably you'll get
completely different uh allocations of
assignments classes yeah so in ice we do
all of that sort of behind the scenes we
tune parameters behind the scenes we
don't expose that to the user
so yes that does impact things and
people we currently don't sort of expose
that
in any way so that people can you know
regularize more
or not or change um the algorithms in
fact what
the initial idea with with ice was to
sort of
um to to hide that all that from the
user and even change
the algorithms not even the parameters
but change the algorithms all together
as you go along to figure out which
algorithms are best suited for the
labels that you have
um i think there's pros and cons to that
if you're an expert you want to have
more control if you're a non-expert
what do the parameters mean not you know
how do you even know what to do so i
think
um it sort of depends again sort of like
how much control you want to have and i
if you do want to have more control then
yes i think you need to expose them in
some way and we don't really know how to
do that
effectively the second question i had
was uh right now you're showing um
uh you said about 200 pages is that
right or 500
as you grow your data set larger and
larger presumably if you have
a million different data points how do
you how do you take those into account
yeah um yeah so that so
with ice ice is designed for people to
sort of build models
um in a few hours so they typically get
up to like 500 or a thousand
examples we also use model tracker for
entity
extraction which often it's at the token
level so we can have
about 10 times more examples uh and for
that we subsample
we subsample and show you just a sub
sample of that in model tracker
we're also looking at different ways of
sort of grouping data
together so you can see sort of groups
of instead of individual examples you
can see groups at the different
positions
and then use that to sort of dive in uh
more so yes um the the larger data sets
you will
we have you know there's more more
things you need to do for that
yeah is there any uh significance
in in terms of how uh the
different data points are laid out
vertically or kind of
oh yeah um yes so um
okay i didn't talk about this but the
bottom half is showing you the training
data the top has half in ice is showing
you the test data
and that's because in ice we
automatically split
the data that you're the user is
labeling because they're starting from
scratch
so we need some set that's for use for
testing
um now we've talked about this because
so
so looking at your test data does not
you mean you have to sort of do it at
your own risk right because you can over
fit your data if you look at it too much
but because miss labels happen in ice we
expose people to the test data
now we're looking at sort of getting rid
of the test it does the stuff at the top
just and just considering all of it as
training data and doing cross-validation
um so that so we sort of eliminate some
of some of those issues
other than that we do so often if you do
have a lot of data as your data set
grows
these can sort of go off the page and so
we sort the problems to the middle
so there's a there's a line here that
sort of splits the top half of the
bottom half
so we sort all the issues to the middle
so that even if
your data grows and it goes off the
screen you know that all the stuff off
the screen is
is being is correct and so you can still
have access to your errors
yep well so you mentioned the issue of
overfitting
so if did you ever see the case where
people were responding to these errors
by like then creating more and more
features is that like an issue that you
might see occurring because people have
such direct access to this
yeah so this is a really interesting
question so
and this kind of goes back to michael's
point right like so people want to click
on their errors they want to click on
these things and
it might mean that they might start over
engineering
their models which is not necessarily
good right
um so we don't really know
what how the what the impact of this is
on
on whether or not they're overfitting um
you know we like the ability to have it
all was available so you can interact
with it but if it is
having you know distracting people then
you know we might want to sort of have
people
sort of pull it up periodically or or
that kind of thing
degrees of freedom and how that's
changing too like yeah like how complex
your model is becoming
that might be cool yeah i think some of
this can be learned actually
also over time and if you can sort of um
go back and forth you know between sort
of like removing features
and seeing if your performance goes up
you know or sort of
maybe we can keep track of like good
states and bad states and sort of help
people sort of
compare that well you were at a better
state when you had fewer
fewer features and sort of show the
comparison and the visualization or
something but
but yeah it's it's definitely people do
want to interact with it and
that's what we wanted but maybe maybe
it's too much you know we don't really
know
yeah you might have missed this you
mentioned that you were using this for
multi-class classification as well
um how would you use that yeah so we
convert multi-class
to binary so for each class you can view
the performance
for that class versus everything else so
you have to switch between it
and again you know i don't think that's
optimal um i think there are better ways
that we can try to design new
visualizations that show all the classes
at once and that's something we're
interested in but right now we use it in
that way and
i mean people still use it people still
find it useful but i think there's more
we can do
the same way that you collected labels
so the first project
you worked on how do people actually
collect labels and helping people
do that so for the end of the extraction
is that something you guys thought about
like how to
facilitate that or have you looked at
work yeah well so i mean people
people collect labels with energy
extraction as well right so they'll
um like the model tracker
yeah yeah with ice you do start from
scratch every time so you'll explore the
universe like
if you're creating an address extractor
for example you'd find some addresses
label the tokens as this is the street
name this is a city name that kind of
thing
and each of those tokens then turn into
a box and model tracker
and we use like a crf for for the entity
extraction
model behind the scenes uh
this perhaps just a suggestion
visualization so once you get rid of the
once you get rid of the training data
from the visualization essentially your
y-axis becomes free right
yeah i think you could potentially
visualize features like that just like
you click on a feature
and then shows vertically this is the
positive is the negative that way that
shows
what the impact of the feature on the
final classification is
so you would like spread it um spread it
according to a future you mean
like with like animation
so we so we show feature correlations
with like overlaying
highlighting um for some of that
but yeah i mean i think there yeah if
you
right the y-axis the y-axis so it's not
showing you much but it's showing you
your the distribution
which can actually also be informative
um
so i think there's an opportunity to
change between like spreading it in one
wave
and then going back to the distribution
um
and yeah we have to sort of explore the
other other
axes and how how we can sort of lay it
out using other information but
yeah i think it's a good idea
okay let's thank selena
you